[Music]
dragon spirit is a tradition of pulling
the hard mod into five threads that
resembles that of the dragon spear
[Music]
people have been making dragon's beard
for thousands of years in china
it was the favorite delicacy of the
royalties
many would say that we are the only
authentic dragon spirit maker here in
singapore
and my name is roger poon i've been
making dragon spirit candy with my
cousin auntie lily for more than 30
years
to me is a delicacy that can be enjoyed
almost every day
before 1988 there weren't anyone making
dragon spirit readily available in
singapore
she is
singapore first dragon beard candy lady
it's a craft she passed on to me and
therefore i am able to continue making
this dragon beard readily available for
one and all to savor here in singapore
first we have to cook the pure mort and
ensure that it can harden into the shape
of a donut
we have to use fresh peanuts
and then we have to crush it into five
bits of peanut crush
from then onwards we will continue using
our strength to pull and to pull and to
pull into the shape of a number eight
until
the threads of mod become even finer
than any human's hair
[Music]
with these fine threads of dragon's
beard we'll wrap it with the crushed
peanut
the dragon sweet candy that is freshly
made will be soft
and smooth when it enters your mouth it
will melt immediately
once i've mastered this craft i give
millennium twist to this ancient recipe
where i add a special ingredient such
that the dragon spirit becomes instantly
crispy and once you put it into your
mouth you are able to breathe out white
smoke that many people call it the
dragon's breath
[Music]
without anybody succeeding my cousin
auntie lily from this trade i decided to
take on the role to continue making this
dragon beard readily available for one
and all here in singapore
i've loved to eat candies since i was
young and it has been a simple pleasure
for me
[Music]
you